y
sus gritos resuenan en el bosque
y nea viven unos 17.000 chimpancés
salvajes la mayor población de áfrica
occidental de lejos a medida que se
acercan a las aldeas se encuentran cada
vez más con los humanos
[Música]
y a veces esos encuentros se vuelven
violentos
esta niña de 4 años es una de las
últimas víctimas en caer presa de los
simios atacada y herida mientras jugaba
en este campo
mi hijo me llamó para decirme que el
chimpancé se había llevado a la bebé
empecé a gritar mi bebé es mi bebé miami
está de burguete el animal la suelto
pero sólo después de haberla mordido y
de haberle arañado la cara
no sé de dónde salió el chimpancé pero
lo perseguí para recuperar a mi hija con
andre kang leyton
el ataque traumatizó a toda la comunidad
los ancianos del pueblo convocaron una
reunión
ante creado que los niños ya no pueden
salir sin supervisión
y
los niños tienen miedo de ir a trabajar
al campo los gritos de los chimpancés
les aterrorizan
cuando salimos del pueblo nos encerramos
en casa nuestros campos nuestros
animales y nuestros niños son atacados
regularmente ya ni siquiera enviamos
estudiantes a la escuela estamos
verdaderamente preocupados y
uno ande en cálculo
los lugareños han talado el bosque para
dar paso a la agricultura porque deja
menos espacio de recursos para los
chimpancés
los ataques de los chimpancés son
resultados directos de la deforestación
ya que los simios se ven obligados a
salir de la selva y dirigirse a tierras
pobladas por personas
para evitar la violencia a los guardias
del parque patrullan constantemente
asegurándose de que ninguna persona
resulte herida y de que ningún animal
sea matado y legalmente si
es una especie protegida no se nos
permite matarle por eso estamos aquí día
y noche
es para evitar enfrentamientos y choques
entre el hombre y el animal emitiendo
tacle confrontación' un punto álgido son
las zonas donde crece esta fruta en
abundancia para los chimpancés les
encantan pero desgraciadamente también a
las personas los lugareños han empezado
a recogerlas para venderlas en los
mercados de alimentos los ataques
continúan y los guardas forestales dicen
que no tienen los recursos necesarios
para evitar futuros enfrentamientos
y poder seguir el rastro de 600 estados
a pie es imposible
no podemos
sólo tenemos un gps para todo el tiempo
para cuatro bosques buscados por las
autoridades regionales dicen que sólo
hay una forma de resolver los continuos
enfrentamientos con los animales pero es
una solución que puede no ser aceptable
para aquellos cuyos trabajos dependen de
la extracción de valor de la tierra
beatriz los seres humanos deben
abandonar los pozos de agua en el monte
el dilema será la comercialización de
bosques silvestres y a la tala ilegal
los árboles son el hábitat del chimpancé
a ver si lo hacemos será fácil convivir
pacíficamente culo si no sirve
la way distance pacific será la acción
pobremente
consejos que no se siguen en medio de la
selva de los chimpancés está esto la
construcción de una carretera que
invadirá aún más su hábitat los
chimpancés están en peligro de extinción
su número en línea está disminuyendo
ah